let's go to our caller from the 6:09
area code who is calling today from 609
hey what a fact my total control is
everyone how you doing good what's going
on alright so a couple observations here
arm I believe that the media movement
has done more damage to women than help
them in terms of this election cycle so
I do believe that why do believe women
have indeed been victimized by men for
centuries quite brutal II in some cases
yes but I believe that women in the
meter movement in their newly acquired
power to terminate powerful men on
accusation alone he said she's
accusation alone it's left them a little
power trunk I think and I think that's
translating in the polls and with the
voters I think that people just simply
don't want to bring in a woman president
right now or at least for this election
cycle so total control let me see if I
can because you're saying a lot I want
to make sure I understand it you're
saying that the the women candidates
currently running like for example
Elizabeth Warren or Kamala Harris who
dropped out or Tulsi Gabbard Amy
Klobuchar they would have more support
today if men hadn't lost jobs because of
allegations of sexual assault is that
your assertion no my assertion is this
women or to be more specific if the me
to movement had been a bit more
responsible with their newly acquired
power that's what I'm saying what's an
example and irresponsibility of the use
of the power of the me to movement well
complete no no due process like effect
yeah but what's an example of the power
being wheeled out what's that what's of
what's an example of that power being
wielded inappropriately Keith said she
said right but look like slanty of that
cases if there's some point okay to go
but total or the meat
hold on Flores with her hair sniffing
plane that was pretty uh crazy if I'm
not mistaken
which story a staffer had a grimace on
his face the entire time that he was
pretty much being forced to cover it so
you're saying the female Democratic
candidates aren't getting more support
because of CNN reporting about Lucy
Flores no that's what you're saying de
but I've already said what I wanted to
say but it's pretty obvious that you're
not really happy with what the narrative
that I've crafted here and that's okay
you don't have to anyway how about if we
move on to Donald Trump because I heard
a couple of uh interesting nicknames for
him
my nickname is Agent Orange and the pun
is intended okay good yeah we've heard
that before so all right so no we're
running low laughs I'm gonna let you go
okay there it is total what was the his
name total control 871 very good thank
you so much for the calls we are out of
time I I'm sorry I wasn't able to get to
everybody but we will take calls again
and I appreciate everybody who did call
in